Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Cabin Cutters, and I'm going to be sharing a very important topic that may be just confirmation to many of you, maybe confrontation to some of you.
But I need to share what's in my heart.
And this is an important topic when you're trying to run a healing ministry as far as having a clinic full of people that have very serious diseases.
Does God still heal?
And then why doesn't God seem to heal everybody? That's the struggle that the wrestling that we have with this, this understanding of our relationship with our Heavenly Father.
And I'm going to try to untangle this a little bit here.
So does God still heal? We read scriptures.
Oh, you can pull up Google and Bible.com or any other Bible program and put in the word heal healing.
And you can see different healing scriptures all through the old and the new testament where God says that he heals.
Psalm 103.2 says bless the Lord, O my soul, and forget none of his benefits. Forget not his benefits. What are his benefits? Well, his benefits are healing. His benefits are the gifts that he gives us.
And the next verse says who partens all our inequities and heals all our diseases. So in the same passage here, we have scripture telling us, if we believe that scripture is God breeds through the solace, the Holy Spirit is saying, bless the Lord, O my soul, and forget none of his benefits.
Who partens all your inequities, who heals all your diseases. And this is what we want to talk about today. Over and over, we see these two things intertwined in scripture, the partied of our inequities or the forgiveness of sins tied with intimately the healing of our diseases.
Isaiah 33, 24, it says, and no resident will say, I am sick talking about the resident of Zion who in Hebrews, it says, we are permitted residents of Zion, the people who dwell there will be forgiven their inequity.
So this lack of sickness and this forgiveness of inequity ties together. Why do we struggle with this then? Isaiah 53, 5 says, but he talking of Jesus was pierced through for our transgressions. He Jesus was crushed for our inequities, the chastisement for all of us fell upon him and by his scourging, we are healed.
So he went to the cross, healing our sickness and forgiving our sins tied together again. First Peter says, and he himself bore our sins in his body on the cross so that we might die to sin and live to righteousness.
For by his wounds, you were healed again, tied healing together with the forgiveness of sins in the same act that was done by that by our works, but by he himself bore our sins in his body on the cross.
By something that was done 2,000 years ago, I have the forgiveness of sins and I can live in right standing with God. That's what righteousness means because of what he did because of what Jesus did and for by his wounds we are healed.
How do we understand that for today? Isaiah 53, 4 was on to say, surely our griefs he himself bore and our sorrows he carried and we ourselves esteemed him, stricken, smitten of God and afflicted. That word griefs is actually a Hebrew word that occurs 24 times in the Old Testament.
20 of the times, say word is interpreted, our sickness he bore himself, our sickness, our griefs, our sorrows, our troubles he bore himself, he bore not me.
Matthew 816 and 17 says what he became they brought to him many who were demon possessed and he cast out the spirits with a word and he healed all who were ill. This was to fulfill this was to fulfill what was spoken through Isaiah the prophet that he himself took our infirmities and carried away our diseases.
So Jesus Christ is the fulfillment of those Old Testament prophecies of taking away our sins and taking away our diseases.
Does God heal now? Does he heal people today? I struggle with that. What am I doing? I'm sick. I'm not feeling well. How do we still get sick if God heals today?
How are we still getting sick? Why are we still getting sick? Why do I have this serious disease if he heals? Well, I'm going to propose a few pieces to this that we can walk through and kind of work this out and untangle it.
So here scripture has these two pieces tangled together throughout scriptures, God, forgiving our sins and healing our diseases. He forgives our inequities and he heals our diseases.
So we're talking about sins and sickness forgives our sins and heals our sickness.
I'm going to propose two things that we need to look at this to understand this for today. One is a perspective over time.
Number one, what's our perspective over time? If we look at time in a realm of array here that it started at one point in time.
If this was our life, this was my beginning. I was bored here and I'm going to die at some point at time from a temporal point of view.
But the Bible says that we are eternal beings. So we might have a temporal ending sometime here, but we go on for eternity.
So this ray means it started at a point and it goes on forever and ever and ever. So this line we could carry on forever and ever and ever and ever and ever and ever and ever and ever.
Forever and ever and ever and ever is a very long time. Our perspective over time is one key to understanding our life today.
So if we could look at our perspective over time and we could look at the sliver of time that I have here on earth.
If we look at this, not just as our timeline, but let's look at this as the human race. The human race began at one certain time, whether you believe it began at the big bay sometime thereafter or what God created.
Adam and Eve, there was a point in time that the human race was created. The Bible is very clear that we live for eternity, whether it be in heaven or hell.
But we were created in the likeness of the image of God, need eternal beings. So we have no end.
If we look at it from that perspective and this is the birth of the human race, this arrow could represent now, whether it's 6000 years or millions of years, depending on what you believe.
This is our life here and it's so small that I couldn't put a dot on that line because in the realm of perspective, this is eternity.
Where I was born in my 90 years, if I'm granted that, is such a small little TD sliver in time that I can't even, I'd have to have a microscope to see the 70 years or 90 years that I'm going to be granted right there.
That's how small that sliver is. It's such a small sliver, but we take that sliver and we blow that sliver.
And because that is our understanding because of what our perspective is, then that sliver becomes everything to us.
Let me propose something to you. And that is if we could understand that perspective, when our perspective is temporal, when we're only looking at that sliver, our picture is perverted.
We are going to be extremely deersighted. That's all we see. That's all I see is myself. That's all I see is this time here I have on earth. This is what it's all about. This is my life.
And so our deersightedness creates blindness. We become blind to everything else. What our perspective is temporal, we become narcissists.
Truly, we are narcissistic. That's all we can see is our life. What I want now for my betterment now.
That is the really, isn't it the definition of sin? I want now for myself when I deem to be the best thing for myself right now.
Right now, I want right now for myself when I have defined to be the biggest and the best of the most beautiful, the most perfect life for me.
That's what I want now. That is by itself the definition of sin. Now, I'm not saying there's anything wrong with you wanting a new car because your old car is falling apart and we really want a new car.
I'm not even asking for a car. I'm asking for healing from this cancer. I would give it a stage for cancer diagnosis and I'm asking for healing for cancer.
I could even care less about a new car or things I've let this, you know, put myself in perspective. I want to be healed from this cancer. Is that still not yet narcissistic?
What I've deemed, what I've defined to be what's best in my life, meaning to be healthy, that's what I want.
And that's all I can see. That's still a temporal picture, even though it might be a very, you know, spiritual perspective.
I don't want things anymore. I don't want fancy houses. I don't want fancy cars. I just want health. That sounds so moral, doesn't it?
And yet still it's coming from our temporal definition of what we think is the biggest and the best of the most perfect for me right now.
We're still looking at things temporal. Our picture is still perverted. Even though there may be a sense of godliness or spirituality, there our picture is still perverted.
We really reveal our cardality. All we're looking at is now, but I won't know for myself that which I've defined to be the best life though, whether it be health or whether it be the new car.
That's our cardality. We're still looking at things in that sliver.
So our perspective over time has to change. If we're good to see how God forgives our inequities and heals our diseases, how he deals with sins, how he deals with sickness, we have to have an eternal perspective.
Paul had an eternal perspective. He was willing to march back into the city after they beat him to a pulp and threw him out left for dead. His friends picked him up and said, oh my gosh, we need to bring you back.
I need to preach the gospel. I want to go back in the city. Are you kidding? We thought you were dead. We're not letting you go back into the city right now. We need to heal.
He was more concerned with fulfilling eternal perspective that he was concerned with fulfilling a temporal having any temporal gain.
He healed to Caesar so he could go to Rome and preach the gospel in Rome knowing full well. He wasn't an idiot that he was probably going to go to his death in Rome and be put to death.
But he thought if I could just preach the gospel to people there, certainly there would be some people that would get saved.
There's an opportunity to get into the hierarchy of leadership to see some people get saved even though it may cost my life.
We could have example after example of those that marched before us and were willing to lay down their temporal gain for any turtle perspective, which would lead to any turtle gain.
The truth is, in the big picture, they were looking out here instead of looking at this pointed time. If we could get our eyes off this pointed time and start looking out here, our perspective of healing would be different.
Because we're going to talk about healing here that God does heal and that healing is for today and that sickness is abolished from a perspective when we look at our position and time.
But the truth is that we're all going to die. Did Jesus heal when he was on earth? We could go back and pull up the scriptures of all the people that Jesus healed.
But guess what? All those people that Jesus healed died. They're all dead. All the apostles are dead.
So, how do we put this in perspective? We have to look at our perspective over time and then we have to look at our position in time.
So, looking at our perspective is how we look at things. So, we're looking at the perspective, how we view things.
Is it that temporal that we're concentrated on? Is it eternal that we're concentrated on? And that our position in time is understated where we're at in this frame of time.
Now time itself may I propose. Is it earthly thing? Time itself is an earthly thing. Time in heaven is not going to exist.
It's going to just be forever. Jesus said, I am whenever anyone asked God who he was, how did he define himself? He said, I am who I am.
There is no beginning. There is no now. There is no to come. He is the epitome of all those three things.
So, as we understand time, he is the alpha and the omega. This is Jesus speaking to John in Revelation.
He is the one who is, that's the present time. He is the one who was the past time and the one who is to come in the future.
He is past, present and future at one time. So, our position in this time of Jesus, forgiving our sins and healing our diseases, is important to understand.
It may I propose that we look at these three words, penalty, power and presence, penalty, power and presence.
The penalty of our sins has been forgiven. This has been taken at the cross. This was a done deal. 2000 years ago, if I have accepted Christ and he is the Lord of my life, this penalty is done.
How do we know that? This is through grace, not through faith, through grace. By grace alone, I received forgiveness of my sins and the penalty of my sins is done.
And I get a spend eternity in heaven. Now, the power over my sin is a present thing. We live in a fallen world. People ask me, well, if you believe in God, how could there still sickness on earth?
Well, because we live in a fallen world, this whole fallen world has not yet been completely redeemed. That is to become in the future.
We still live in this fallen world. There is still sin. I have power. Only power offered by sin is through God's grace again. This is all through grace.
Sins have been forgiven. The penalty of sins been forgiven through grace. The power of sin. I have any power that I have over sin is through grace. Do I still sin today?
Absolutely. I sinned and thought indeed on a daily basis. And it's only through grace that I again have forgiveness. That penalty was already done. It's a done deal on the cross.
And that power over sin today is how much I depend upon the Holy Spirit and am able to overcome the fallen world that I'm dealing with.
The presence of sin is going to be abolished in the future. When we get to heaven, there's going to be no sin.
It's the same thing with sickness. In the future, when I get to heaven, when you get to heaven, there's going to be no sickness. There's going to be no sickness in heaven.
There's going to be no power necessary for to have over sickness because it's not going in heaven because the presence of sickness is going to be gone.
The presence of sin is going to be gone in heaven. There'll be no sin. There'll be no sickness in heaven.
Okay, this is where we're living right here. This is today. I've relied on grace for the power over sin and I've relied on grace for the power over sickness.
Is sickness going to eventually overtake me? This side of heaven? Absolutely. As much as I said, every single person that Jesus healed died.
He rose Lazarus from the dead. Well, it doesn't tell us anything in Scripture, but I got news for you. Lazarus died eventually. I don't know, 10 years later, 5 years later, 2 months later, we don't know.
Most likely it was after the resurrection of Christ, but he died. So did all the apostles. So those that give us some, there's some ministries out there that say if you have enough faith and we'll talk about that in a second,
that you will not be sick and you will not have cancer and you can overcome that. That is just baloney. That is not true. If that is true, then God has to apologize for every single human being that is a believer that has now died over the last 2,000 years because they're all died.
We don't live forever if you had perfect healing this side of heaven. Healing is for today. Forget us as sins is for today, but we live in a fallen world and it's only received through grace and it's only going to be for a period of time.
And it's only till we get to heaven that we're going to be in the presence of no sickness and no sin.
So how do we receive healing if there is healing for today? How do we receive it? Well, the answer is no different than how we receive forgiveness of sins. It's only through grace.
How do we receive healing? It's only through grace. So how do we receive this forgiveness of healing for by grace alone? We have been saved through faith. That's not of ourselves. It's not of works. It's only a gift of God.
So beware of these two extremes. There are two extremes out there that I hear on a weekly basis from people.
Number one extreme was healing was dispensational. God doesn't heal today. And my argument with that is that is absolute melodie. If God doesn't heal today, then none of the other scripture that we can claim for today counts for today either.
Not only is healing not dispensational. My claim is that because you are breathing right now is evidence that you are walking in a healing right now.
Because the opposite of being healed is you're you're not alive. You don't have the power to even to even take a breath.
Colossians says that Jesus not only created the earth. He sustains it. He sustains our our very being. The fact that I could even communicate to you that I am my heart is being is a sign that I am walking in a healing right now.
The other extreme is healing is based on your faith. So if you're not healed from your cancer right now, you don't have enough faith. You need to have more faith. And it's and it's all about your faith. Understand both when I say healing isn't for today.
It was only in the Old Testament and it was only for Jesus to and the Apostles because there's a book of Acts that that the Apostles and Jesus could give healing to people and grant healing to people because it was only to show the power of God.
You need that anymore because we have the Bible. No, that's just nonsense. He lead is existing. No, the fact that you you have food to eat. It's because of the gift of God. The fact that you have anything that you have is a gift of God.
This really is a works base. When you really think of it, if healing is not for today, how is anybody healed? How do you live? How do you have anything? That means you've earned it.
If healing isn't for today, I only got over cancer because I had I ate this great diet and I used to write the sheet and I did all these wonderful things. That's all works based. And yes, we are supposed to be stewards of this temple.
So there are things that we are supposed to do in a godly sense. We're supposed to take care of ourselves. We're supposed to stay in shape. We're supposed to not overeat or not supposed to abuse this temple. We are supposed to eat the right things and we're supposed to we are called to use wisdom in our life.
But the healing comes from God. So if we're completely works based here, we're leaving out grace. This other extreme, I see the most damaging of all of the churches and ministries that talk about if you don't have enough faith, that's why you're not healed. It's just from the devil.
Nowhere does it say in scripture that because of your lack of faith that you aren't receiving a gift of God.
Throughout scripture, there's times where it was because of the woman who came to Jesus and touched his cloth and she said, well, it's because of your faith that you are healed.
But it was not faith in what she, what she could possess. It was her faith in God's grace that healed her.
So don't get that confused. We make anything, anything in scripture is a work based that we are walking in cardality.
This is totally a gift of God. How do I receive this gift of God? I have cancer and this is not looking good. What do I do? I want to be healed. We have to keep our perspective. Go back to your perspective.
What are we looking at? Are we being nearsighted? Is this all we're looking at here?
Is this picture right here? What is our position over time? We are healed and we need to walk in that healing, but it may not, we may not see that full healing, that full lack of presence of sickness until heaven.
In fact, we're for sure not. Even if God does heal you of this cancer right now and your numbers go back to normal and you got your energy back and your power back, you're still going to die. I got news for you and tell unless the rapture comes before you we get to that time, you're still going to die.
You're going to ask for healing then and if God doesn't give it to you then, then are you going to lose faith then? We got to keep our perspective. What is our role then? What is our role as a believer? What are we supposed to do then? We need to just ask.
We ask for healing and then we rest in the sovereignty of God. God is sovereign. If he wants to heal me this side of heaven, then praise God that I can live for a few more years. Hey, I have today, why don't I start being thankful for that?
Instead of always looking out into the by little temporal future that I don't want to die and I have cancer and I don't want to die. So I just prayed that God heals me praying that God heals me. Maybe we should start praying and I know this is going to be a slap of the face to some but I'm speaking to myself here.
Maybe I need to start praying instead of praying over and over and over and over and over and spending my time praying that God heals me. I need to say, Lord, how do you want to use this in my life?
You and your sovereignty knew that this is going to happen. You allowed it to happen in my life. How do you want to use me through this? How can I be a witness to you through this sickness?
Maybe it's how I handle this sickness. Maybe it's how I look at it and change my perspective in my life, my relationship with my spouse, my relationship with my children, my dealing with others that I have.
I don't think God's going to ship you off to Timbuktu to go witness but God wants to use you right where you're at.
What do you need to work on right where you're at that you could use this present illness to be a blessing to somebody else to be ministry to somebody else.
Now, the only way I could do that is if I take this type of perspective, this eternal perspective, if I stay focused on me right now in my sickness and my pain and my struggles, I'm always going to be in this temporal perspective.
I have to get out of that and get rid of my dear sighted this and look at it from a far sighted perspective. Lord, it's not about right now.
What if it's his make? I'm dealing with a serious illness and I may only have months to live.
So what? How can I serve you right now, Lord? I want to be like Paul and say, well, go to say, if it was just about me, if you're looking at it from really an eternal perspective, if it's just about me, then heck, I'd rather go and be with the Lord.
It's not about here. I'd rather be here. I only want to be here. See, he flipped it completely upside down.
We go, I want to be here. I want to live longer. I want to see my grandkids. I want to see my daughter get married and those are all good, godly things. Those are all really wonderful, but they're self-centered in their temporal.
Paul flipped it upside down. If I was only thinking about myself, I'd rather be in heaven.
Hey, there's going to be no sit there. There's going to be no sickness there. And you get endless blueberry muffins. Good to say. I'm going to heaven.
But for the sake of you, Paul said, for the sake of others, for the sake of ministry, for the sake of helping others out. I'd rather be here.
And that's the perspective we need to take. Lord, heal me. I ask that you heal me, but not for temporal reasons so that I can serve more.
And Lord, if this is what you have me going through, which it obviously is, then teach me how I can serve you through this more and how this can be a ministry so that others can understand you and see you better.
Thank you very much. Just give you a little bit different perspective. All right. Bye-bye.